اختم بسؤال سريع ان شاء الله همم حوالي
88,000 مشترك في قناتك يوتيوب ما شاء الله
تبارك الله نعم 64000 متابع في انستغرام
480,000 متابع في تويتر 22,000 معجب
بصفحتك في فيسبوك ولك وجود كبير في سناب
شات مدري كم الرقم
800,000 تقريبا ما شاء الله تبارك
ليش الناس يتوجه الى برايك الى الى خالد
الدكتور خالد منيف وغيره من الناس
المهتمين بالتطوير الذات والتنميه البشريه
وغيرها من الامور يعني مثلا كان في برنامج
ثمانيه في الوتساب
مقارنه بمقابلات مهمه تتعلق بحياه الناس
لبعض يقول بانه الناس
تهو اليوم البعد عن واقعها وحياته الاتجاه
نحو الخيال والاحلام
والمستمدين الفاضله والافلاطونيه
وهذه الصفات اللي قبل شوي ذكرتها في في
الشخص الملكي ههه
يعني يختلف معك لاننا نحس نشعر بشيء من
الغضن لان هناك بعض المحتويات زين ارقامها
الارقام فلكيه جدا لكن في المقابله
يربط على كتفه يا اخي بالكلمات
امل في الحياه هذه يريد من يعطي والله
والله شيء من نقول الوصايا الجميله في
تعاملات الحياه في النظر الى مستقبليه في
التعامل مع ماضيه يريدون اخلاص يا اخي
تعبوا الناس تعبوا الان حرفيا
كبيره
مثل هذه الامور وانا ما اتكلمنا
والكلمه يا اخي يا اخوي خالد بالابتسامه
يا اخي عبس بالابتسامه بالكلمه زينه
بالكامل الناس ترى لا يريدون منك مالها
كلمه طيبه كلمه طيبه قصه هادفه زين معاني
جميله في الحياه التجربه شخصيه زين تغير
وانا اقول الانسان دائما واقول لمن له في
هذا الاتجاه لا تحقرن من المعروف شيخ
والان متواجد المحتوى الهادف الان اعتبره
فرض عين فرض عين هل هل المد هائل همم
تحتاج الى امثاله